6 heures du matin le jour se lève sur la
place elliptique à le lieu de rendez
vous quotidien de tous les équatoriens à
la recherche d'un travail au black
depuis trois ans une sévère crise
économique être un espagne à madrid les
500000 émigrés équatoriens la prennent
de plein fouet
ici les règles ont changé avant le
travail au noir était réservé aux sans
papiers aujourd'hui ils sont des
centaines de travailleurs légaux à
espérer à un job de quelques heures ou
de quelques jours maintenant ça
fonctionne de la même façon que le
marché noir
les patrons ne veulent pas donner un
contrat de travail
mais ici la plupart des personnes ont
des papiers kléber est arrivé en espagne
en 1996 le pays alors en plein boom
économique comptable en équateur il
devient topographe à madrid pendant 13
ans avant de se faire licencier en 2009
le début d'une longue traversée du
désert aujourd'hui j'ai un vrai
sentiment de douleur parce que je me
sens impuissant
début 2000 en équateur la machine à
billets nourrit une inflation de près de
100 % par an pour sauver sa tête le
président jamil mahuad annonce alors la
dollarisation de l'économie
la première en amérique latine pour les
classes moyennes le résultat est
catastrophique
le pouvoir d'achat s'effondre et l'exil
devient la solution la terre promise est
vite choisi même langue
âge d'or économique direction le pays de
l'ancien colon l'espagne à madrid
autour de la place le manège est bien
rodé les pistoleros les chefs de
chantier viennent en voiture chercher de
la main d'oeuvre équatorienne bon marché
le tarif 20 euros par jour et hop une
cotisation sociale
[Musique]
l'écart est un peu
triste constat beaucoup de volontaires
et peu d'élus à madrid les autorités
préfèrent fermer les yeux
selon les équatoriens un véritable
braquage légal fin de journée sur par là
un quartier prend les terres du sud de
madrid
aujourd'hui kléber était serrurier il a
travaillé 12 heures pendant le faste des
années 2000 l'état développe une
politique soutenue de facilitation
d'accès à la propriété
kléber s'achète un appartement puis
vient le temps du chômage et des dettes
depuis un an il ne peut plus rembourser
la saisie de son logement est imminente
ce soir il a rendez vous avec ivan alami
économiste venu pour le conseiller
[Musique]
je me cherchais le document que m'a
envoyé le tribunal pour me réclamer
l'argent perdus dans la jungle
administrative des dizaines de milliers
d'équatoriens comme kleber se sont fait
escroquer par les banques espagnoles
ils ont souscrit sans le savoir des
crédits à taux variable avec un contrat
facile à signer les impossible à lire
comment tu peux lire ça c'est illisible
anglais je ne sais pas comment je vais
faire pour le lire et comprendre ce qui
est marqué et encore nous on parle
espagnol
on peut comprendre ce qui est écrit le
problème c'est qu'on ait ni juriste ni
avocat avant je payais 930 euros par
mois puis il y a deux ans est monté à
1200 euros
et aujourd'hui je paye 1499 euros par
mois c'est vraiment impossible
mais ce qui effraie kléber c'est la
double peine une loi espagnole qui
oblige les personnes à rembourser la
totalité de leurs crédits même après la
saisie du logement un peu de lumière
c'est ça la réalité que je vis ici
quand j'aurai trouvé une solution je
voudrais rentrer chez moi le plus vite
possible et ça c'est ça ma réalité à
madrid celle qui aident les sinistrés
équatorien victime de la crise
immobilière et des arnaques bancaire
s'est elle aida qui nato à une indienne
quechua de 45 ans le visage façonné par
le soleil le vent et le froid des
montagnes andines aïda est employée de
maison à madrid
elle gagne 700 euros par mois bonjour je
voudrais un petit fromage
il ya du maïs par là j'aimerais bien
voir du bon maïs et ça c'est vraiment
une petite douceur
pour faire face à la crise aida à la
solution une économie parallèle importé
d'équateur dans un monde réel comme ici
il faut acheter
c'est la réalité mais dans un monde
idéal la solution serait d'utiliser le
troc
on essaie de le faire ici petit à petit
le troc c'est une façon de lutter contre
la crise en espagne le chômage atteint
actuellement 20% de la population 30%
chez les immigrés
[Musique]
quartier de sainte bias l'un des plus
pauvres de la banlieue madrilène
aujourd'hui aïda rendez vous avec des
amis de l'association conadi dont elle
est présidente
ensemble ils espèrent trouver une
solution au problème des hypothèques
poubelles dont est victime entre autres
la communauté équatorienne il faut qu'on
continue à voir comment on s'organise
tout ce qui a été demandé tout ce qui a
été fait et tout ce qui peut être fait
tout ce qui a été fait dans les médias
est partout et là on pourra établir nos
revendications
ici c'est un peu le bureau des pleurs
tous ont lourdement surendettés c'est le
cas de mercy et de son crédit de 230000
euros c'est pas possible de vivre comme
ça on ne peut pas s'acheter de meubles
on ne peut pas manger mieux
on ne peut pas aller au ciné il faut
payer l'hypothèque
on ne peut pas sortir dîner parce qu'il
faut payer l'hypothèque
on est des esclaves de l'hypothèque il
nous paye un salaire pour ne pas qu'on
meurt parce qu'ils ont besoin de nous
pour les enrichir
ça c'est une nouvelle forme d'esclavagé
une maison ou un appartement saisie et
en plus un crédit sur 20 30 et parfois
50 ans à rembourser les banques
espagnoles se servent deux fois sur le
dos des équatoriens littéralement
étranglée par un système aberrant au
sein de la communauté
le ras-le-bol est immense beaucoup
rêvent de rentrer au pays
un retour illusoire conditionné par
l'acquittement de leur dette
au sud de madrid quelques terrains de
fortune le rayon de soleil des
équatoriens dans un quotidien difficile
c'est les quads au lit un volley ball
médine équateur je fais je sèche le
terrain les quoi boli c'est le sport
national avec le football
un filet et trois joueurs par équipe un
sport qui ne coûte rien chaque week-end
en équateur on joue à l'éco aboli a
juste besoin de deux poteaux un filet
dessiner les limites du terrain et une
balle et c'est bon ici pas un terrain
deco abolissant vendeurs ambulants
au menu boissons et plats typiques du
pays il vous reste des mollahs me oui
mon reste bien chaud serre moi c'était
ça un gobelet je ne t'aime pas le terme
recherché c'est bien pour oublier les
problèmes du quotidien
la crise pour oublier un peu la crise
pour se distraire c'est l'objectif de
tout ça aujourd'hui kléber espère un
compromis avec son créancier
la saisie de son logement mais pas le
remboursement de son prêt échelonné sur
35 ans peu de chances d'y parvenir
le droit espagnol est aujourd'hui du
côté des banques